[Music]
in high end racism news Oh classy racism
that DG you [ __ ] up what's DG Paul took
my may be submitted by Jay Wong ster
wants the Italian fashion designers
Dolce and Gabanna have apologized for a
racist behavior he was saying Stefano
right he was like Marcia got hats that
wasn't me
how racist though oh pretty racist it
has to unfold a certain way because the
first thing you're gonna see it's not
gonna feel that racist well what
happened I don't even know what else see
did he like take my let you take the
floor chair take it away
this Dolce & Gabana two people two dudes
two girls it's like Ben and Jerry oh so
don't take Ivana they were gonna have
this huge fashion show in Shanghai they
[ __ ] up they thought somehow that it was
a great idea to have these like ads
posted on Weibo which is like the
Chinese platform like Twitter forum and
so they end up posting these ads where
there's this Chinese girl she approaches
food Italian food and then she's like oh
I don't know how to use chopsticks with
these Italian food okay so I'm going to
show you some clips of those ads where a
Chinese girl does not use Chinese girl
and then how to eat Italian food like
pizza and a cannoli
oh I could eat a pizza with chopsticks
easy me too easy because because that's
not the food you're not supposed to eat
that food with chopsticks yeah but even
my mom eats pizza which I'm Yuki any
food with chopsticks
yeah but then the way that they
portrayed this was kind of like she was
stupid
yes using the tongue just that you do it
too so this video will not to show you
the first half of the first section is
those ads okay okay the second section
is some dams that were leaked from
Gabbana's the second section is the
[ __ ] up that's the [ __ ] up even more
okay
so that part you're gonna see some
some dance where he's calling China
country of [ __ ] like yeah totally being
racist yeah and then the last yeah
unless you're Chinese you're not allowed
to call China
let your agent oh man I do it all the
time you're married to one so as long as
you let Chinese give me permission
as long as China's entering you you can
say whatever you want thank you so then
the last part of this video I'm about to
show you is a little section of their
apology video cuz [ __ ] just hit the fan
Wow and they were just like oh my god we
need to do some damage control because a
third of our sales are from China market
[Applause]
that's a big-ass cannoli he's a really
bad actor
oh my god what do you download there hey
hey hey
Mandarin interpreter you do you know
what they were saying yeah he was like
trying to give her directions like Oh
pick up the pasta pick up the pasta pick
up the pasta just like that so that was
that commercial aired in China it was on
Weibo is because marketers some
marketers are so [ __ ] old and stupid
that they don't even know that their
jokes are so outdated to the point where
everybody's like dude that's like that's
like that's like making fun of like
black people picking cotton and [ __ ] and
anything that's so funny yeah so that's
pretty much what happen here so then
that's when someone Dan Gabbana and said
like you know you're being racist and
all this stuff and he was like why do
you think it's racist that video I see
it's exactly my point
he's like Chinese eat with chopsticks
and the and that the Westerners with the
fork and knife how is this race the
earth is this racism and then
so you were racist because you eat dogs
oh yeah who said that
come on oh they said that Ilana said
this I think he was like I will say that
the country of [ __ ] is China China
ignorant dirty smelling mafia who said
his English is terrible
well he's Italian you guys deal with the
Italian accent to make it right he was
gonna respond like Italian and then Yin
stands up he ends up posting this this
is not me I got back I love China
between these cultures no you like shiny
money you'll be funny he was like I love
China and then he's doing this in a
picture you know be closer what the
Chinese I don't know why but it sounds
like a hat wait you know when people
respond back to you it like when this
hat it sounds like that though yeah does
it sound like the owner of Dolce known
for sang [ __ ] like one time he commented
on Selena Gomez's photo saying that
she's ugly Italian dude he sounds like
an old man that lost connection with the
world I'd be waiting to bring more
evolved it and then do a polygraph test
see if he's really a lion or not those
are legit yeah for sure
so then that's when they started posting
this on their Instagram saying like art
even the DNG Instagram account has been
hacked and then like all this stuff
right so stupid it was the guy on the
left no it's gone the right for sure
gone the right you're just guessing
he was the one that was talking most of
the video he does that anything but then
throws it someone's gonna [ __ ] it up
that's why yeah so then throughout the
whole video
there were people were saying like they
do not mean this [ __ ] that they're
saying because they're just like looking
off to the side and they're just like
just like they say it in English no in
Italian what more do you want to give
apology so many more to say I mean you
know we take our Fuji the schools I
think wisdom essential message research
we have a gun behind their head or what
that's what it looks like the country a
lot we put anything there grinding their
teeth they don't want to do it dude that
[ __ ] look like a place they know they
lost money like a Taliban captive video
dude like what the [ __ ] right and then
who gets who buys don't cheating Cavani
like have you guys bought Asians so
there's a lot see that's why they're
saying that again you're right it's the
money before China Japan was the number
one purchaser of luxury goods from
Europe but now if you have Japan China
and South Korea and Singapore and
Indonesia Malaysia all the richest
people in Asia [ __ ] buy this [ __ ] up
it's not the u.s. it's not Europe their
biggest [ __ ] market share is Asia
Asian why would you do that exactly if
you schanke's on chip its Instant Karma
though which is awesome right because
then that Chinese show that they were
that fashion show there we're gonna be a
lot of huge celeb celebrities and
influencers going to that show and then
immediately after this came out everyone
started posting not me over like for
example the model Oh they'd be like not
me like I'm not gonna show up in that
show and then all these celebrities are
like um banning dodging the water from
my closet and then they started taking
them down from a lot of these Chinese
and so like they stopped selling Dolce
Gabanna and people started burning their
stuff yeah oh no why'd you burn it I
mean you already paid for it do you know
if people in China were offended with
the with the commercial it was all of it
so it was like all clumped together so
some people that like the way they
reacted was just like oh that's just
like poor taste they're just ignorant
they think that like what are we in the
1800's like these are old stereotypes
but then what what really made it worse
was the Lana's judyann's that were
leaked yeah so that's what pissed people
off I could get that and then also the
apology video piss people off so
terrible
yeah legit look like [ __ ] Osama bin
Laden was in front of the camera and he
had an ak-47 to his head
took days to for them to respond so just
like you [ __ ] you just only care
about the money maybe I don't I don't
get as mad it's stuff like this cuz
they're so old
I feel like old people only always get
like yeah before on the verge of
retardation that 50% path is like if
you're old you [ __ ] old [ __ ] you're
gonna die anyways yeah they're stuck in
their own ways there's no way you can
change them so for them it's like
obviously they're just gonna change for
the sake of money yeah but it's like
they're it's really hard to change
someone's beliefs you know well I mean
oh oh
go with that a little bit what you guys
are saying cuz it's like yes if they're
ignorant and they have those jokes or
whatever fine but I think once they like
start putting people down like publicly
like that I'm like dude that's well I'm
not saying old people can't get it to
like they can you can change yeah what I
am saying is that for me it doesn't make
me as angry as if that was a younger
person because I give us alms or
something yeah cuz a younger person who
has a connection to the youth can
influence the youth in a very negative
way that guy's not inclusive it isn't it
good then he came out like this cuz now
he's learning his lesson the hard way
and in a way that he'll never forget
oh for sure I bet you a stubborn ass is
just like thinking that everyone else is
still wrong and he's rich as [ __ ] so
he's got a bunch of yes people egomaniac
[ __ ] yeah because I'm pretty
sure he's walking around and saying like
ching chong ching chong like it's funny
and workers aren't gonna say [ __ ] it's
cuz oh people don't evolve their jokes
like they have the jokes from 19 [ __ ]
10 or whatever the Great Depression
I think it's classless people though cuz
my grandma was old and she didn't
understand a lot of Asian stuff cuz I
had a lot of Asian boyfriends not a lot
but I had Asian boyfriends but she
wouldn't make jokes you know what I mean
like I've never heard her make racial
jokes so she just made comments that you
can tell she was ignorant I've just had
like Chinese voodoo dolls in a room I
think that's just a racist person like I
don't think it's old people I think it's
just races a lot of old people can't
reason though because they're not good
at
I would say old traditional people like
people that are educated and they
understand how to reason and use facts
and things like that they think very
differently
exactly
example my mom she's always telling me I
have to take more emergency or more
airborne because our amenities just
aren't strong at white people's oh no
that's not true vitamin or you could
overdose on vitamins and [ __ ] yeah but
that's just her logics wrong everybody
like the wipers in superior yeah her
logic is like if I'm here with the white
person under the AC I'm gonna get
pneumonia that's not true you know that
you just can't change that like no
matter what my mom's making like ginseng
[ __ ] ginger soup like every single
night didn't she think Japanese people
were tall as hell because I ate noodles
because they ate noodles versus this
guy's completely different like for her
she's just stating it as like like hey
unfortunately we don't have no see but
she's not saying like oh because you're
white like they're dirty and yeah she's
not a comedian and then now your jokes
your jokes are based off that logic so
these guys have super dumb logic and
then I think they also have famed
they're comedians and which is why they
have like these horrible joke you know I
think it's really dope though a time I
responded though cuz they're [ __ ]
scared like they're [ __ ] their pants
because there's no chain kibana dude
that was a crappy kiyah show the
commercial itself was crap it wasn't it
was not a good commercial right what a
China do ya Wiley's can play this whole
thing where they're like banning like
all the celebrities like they're all
coming together to say [ __ ] Dolce all oh
I think is dope like they all came
together they're just like we're
speaking with our money like we're not
buying your [ __ ] that's smart
they buried their own grave yeah sorry
you don't air something like that and
think there's no millions of people way
to do it though like your dollar speaks
louder than anything I don't need back I
feel like if Nike says something racist
though I don't think I would stop
wearing Nike but no I love that you yeah
they're like [ __ ] Chinese people [ __ ]
Korean people unlike Dhanbad your shoes
are so nice
[Music]